the investigation begins after hours the
museum is tense with anticipation Mona
Lisa is leaving her bulletproof cell
she's due for her most thorough health
check in 500 years a process documented
in this series of photographs under the
watchful eyes of curators and scientists
the Mona Lisa moves to a conservation
lab beneath the Louvre during the course
of three 36-hour sessions
the painting is weighed measured
photographed x-rayed and scan it is the
most comprehensive test of an artwork in
human history we are asked to study the
painting for one main reason the main
reason is a stability of the panel the
painting is not painted on canvas but on
panel the concerned that Louvre had was
the effect of temperatures and humidity
and the warping it's a wood panel and
before the kite has a lot of distortion
associated with it and by using this
technology were hoping to be able to
record the exact shape so that it can
study the physical behavior of the
painting is the painting deteriorating
besides assessing the paintings physical
condition the high-tech regimen helped
Mona Lisa tell her story
space-age devices gave voice to the
evidence embedded in Leonardo's
materials and methods the data required
more than a year to process but as the
results took shape the team of art
historians and curators posed an
extraordinary and controversial question
was the Mona Lisa a portrait of a
pregnant woman one of the tests was a
photographic process called infrared
reflectography
the science is complex but it boils down
to this an infrared camera can
photograph details we can't see when the
camera peered through the paintings
darkened varnish it detected something
unusual about Mona's attire
according to Bruno motae one of the
curators who organized the testing the
models seem to be enveloped by a
transparent gauze like veil I could
observe that there was girls on the left
arm that will also goes on the right arm
and the mother seems to be totally
enveloped in the transparent goes so I
deduced that the model was totally
enveloped by you're sort of from a
second dress the discovery led to new
speculation some historians believe the
second dress may be a guar nello
a garment thought to be worn by pregnant
women or new mothers this painting by
Sandro Botticelli a contemporary of
Leonardo depicts a woman wearing a guar
nello and that woman in the butcher
painting is pregnant if Mona Lisa's veil
is indeed aguar nello it suggests that
the painting alludes to some aspect of
motherhood some have even wondered if
Mona herself
might be pregnant Leonardo's depiction
of Mona Lisa's hands may support this
provocative theory one scholar a medical
doctor sees her hands as swollen or
puffy a typical sign of pregnancy
others however insist that Lisa's hands
are shaped by Renaissance ideals of
beauty and nothing more the Renaissance
Yves would Mar at large female hands and
there's a treated spy guy called fear
and swallow from the middle of the 16th
century in which he talks about these
large hands and long fingers they were
desirable so large hands was in and if
you look at the hands for instance of
Leonardo's to chili gala Danny you see
that they're huge